in the morning i'll come in sort of my
admin i always do my day plan the night
before soon as i walk in the next day i
don't have to sit there for 20 minutes
thinking what i'm going to do and if you
do it the night before everything's
fresh in your head of what's gone right
and what's gone wrong essentially so you
can build on that the next day so that
saves time in the morning so come in do
all my admins sort out my emails i might
build some more lists that i'm going to
approach for bd or sort out some
projects and stuff on linkedin just get
everything sort of lined up that i need
to sort admin wires go back to people
and then as soon as half 12 comes half
12 is half seven in new york so i'll get
on the phone and for an hour and a half
just purely do bd so catching managers
before work so i might be calling
project leads and companies that are
implementing workday general managers i
know that are hiring and have been hard
to get hold of so i smash the phones for
an hour and a half and then i'll
typically have some lunch at my desk for
15 20 minutes and then assess if i need
to either find candidates for rolls or
do that for we typically split things up
into sprint so two hours per sprint of
just focusing on one particular thing so
that might be just sourcing candidates
so right for the next two hours i'm just
going to find candidates for x100 i'm
just going to call through these hundred
candidates here that could be just to
generate leads or whatever it is and
then again assess my day and come back
to more bd but i think recruitment
there's not too many things you can do
it's a mixture of candid sourcing
business development but always like
throughout the week you've got to build
in things that are going to generate
business outside of that where it could
just be like legion it could just be
doing some market research and i think
another important thing is to set
yourself non-negotiable target so if you
want to be successful and then and you
know build a lot of money you've got to
be hitting targets that you set yourself
whether that is a certain amount of cvs
you get a day a week a certain amount of
client calls that you have with managers
so like typically what we say here is
that you've got to send out a certain
amount of spec cvs per week targeted
specs i'm not talking about bring up 100
people and just spec in absolute i'm
talking about random yeah get a good
candidate into a project of a company
you know that would need that person
that's a targeted specs gonna actually
get a job we typically say you should
speak to ten candidates per day and five
hiring damages per day as a minimum if
you do that every week there's 50
candidates you've spoken to and 25
hiring managers if you do that every
week for a month i can guarantee you
you'll be successful unless you go onto
those calls and as i said come away with
something that is either if you speak to
a candidate
get their permission send them to a
vacancy get some market knowledge get a
referral of another candidate i think is
good get a lead or get a manager or two
they've worked for before if you're
speaking to a hiring manager don't be
afraid to push them if they're like
right i'm not speaking to you i'm not
right just keep pushing them and say you
know who is right who can i speak to
what is who is right yeah exactly is
there a better time for me to call you
back and then follow them up with an
email saying thanks for your time sorry
i interrupted you i'll give you a call
back at this time on that date just so
that you show that you're on top of
things and good at what you do
[Music]